tomorrow's here tomorrow's take some
breaking news uh tomorrow about um
abramovic
yes we're just seeing on the reuters
news agency and obviously we're urgently
checking this that roman abramovich has
now been added to the uk sanctions list
so that is a huge move of course the the
russian oligarch and tycoon who's been
in the uk for two decades has just put
chelsea football club up for sale can
now have his assets frozen so that
includes of course his
property portfolio we heard from the
labour mp chris bryant that he's already
put his uh mansion in chelsea palace
gardens in london up for sale um he's
got reportedly other properties yachts
and so on the british government has now
added him to that sanctions list so
jeopardizing potentially the sale of the
football club before the bids have come
in i was just about to say i mean we
don't necessarily know at this stage but
what might it mean for chelsea because
he didn't he give it to some sort of
charitable giver charitable trust we're
waiting for the full details of of what
it will mean but he hadn't even had any
bids in for it yet um and of course um
the rest of his property portfolio and
other assets um built up over 20 years
in london now up for grabs um
interesting that the government have
done this because of course they will
have to have made sure that any case
against him is legally watertight he has
taken legal action in the past against
people claiming that he has very strong
links with vladimir putin he um for
those who don't know of course made a
lot of money during the collapse of the
soviet union um was the governor of a
province um in a in uh far away part of
russia in putin's first year as
president before coming to london and um
was described in a high court case um
just back in 2012 as someone with very
uh close relations with putin but
something he's disputed okay and i'm
asking you questions you might not know
the answer to but does this mean that
potentially the british government will
will own chelsea football club i think
all of that is tbc given the the very
complicated arrangements right the image
there isn't a charitable trust but
certainly um this is this is a move
against probably britain's best-known
russian oligarch and they must be pretty
sure if they have added him to the
sanctions list at this stage because the
way it's been put to me by people in
government so far questions about why
him he and others have not been
sanctioned yet is we don't want anybody
going to the courts and appealing it and
giving vladimir putin a propaganda
victory so they must be pretty sure that
they can do this um chris bryant the
labour mp told parliament that not just
the football club but some of the
properties had been put up for sale as
well in anticipation of this happening
and we understand that potentially other
russian oligarchs are going to be added
to that list today i've got another
question if i may again you know i'm
just sort of this story has literally
only just happened ladies and gentlemen
so you know it's fascinating stuff can
you stay in the uk
um he his assets will be frozen and i've
just actually seen um an email from the
government confirming that not just
roman abramovich but also oleg derapaska
are among seven oligarchs targeted um
with that with their sanctions hit so
there'll be
travel bans and sanction and transport
sanctions imposed so oleg deripaska
is was abramovich's business partner at
one stage and he um remember peter
mandelson being on his yacht
he's someone very well connected in
politics and so both of them politics um
and yeah indeed and he has um he runs
the en plus
energy group um you've also got several
other individuals we're just seeing the
names now uh eagle section who's the
chief executive
rosneft big russian
energy company andre costin the chairman
of one of russia's biggest banks vtb
um alexei miller the head of the energy
company gazprom which we recently found
out that a lot of nhs trusts buy their
energy from
another senior figure at the
russian-owned pipeline company trasneft
and dimitri labodev of the rocia bank
boris johnson saying there can be no
safe havens for those who have supported
putin's vicious assault on ukraine
today's sanctions are the latest step in
the uk's
unwavering support for the ukrainian
people we will be ruthless in pursuing
those who enable the killing of
civilians destruction of hospitals and
illegal occupation of sovereign allies
so boris johnson clearly feels very
confident in linking those individuals
to the conflict talk about levidad
though it's not of gaining not even
evidence to clarify for viewers
the owner of the independent who's in
the newspaper at the weekend to know
dimitri
lebedev from rossia bank but the big
names there abramovic and oleg deripaska
okay obviously being sanctioned